ah vodka always a good choice strong
smooth delightfully clear vodka is
usually made from potatoes grapes or
wheat one man is doing things
differently he's making vodka from yes
you heard that right
sheep we are in birches bay in tasmania
australia 16 years ago my family night
built our sheep cheesery from scratch i
was getting tired of just doing the sort
of cheese things and so i came up with
the idea of distilling matter how by
using way so way is essentially part of
cheese making and in a lot of cases put
down the drain and wasted I have figured
out a way to turn that into a product
making vodka from whey is quite unusual
there had been a couple of successful
attempts but no one had ever made a
sheep's way vodka until Ryan came along
it took him about a hundred attempts
over the course of a year but he got
there so step one we milk the sheep and
then give it to our cheese factory who
then makes it into a cheese and then the
way is what's left over
step two I grabbed that way and then
adding enzymes it ferments into alcohol
what essentially creates alcohol is a
basic sugar and my basic sugar is
lactose step 3
I grab that alcohol and distill it twice
into a finished spirit and step four i
aged the spirit for four months Step
five we actually hand paint the entire
bottle so we spray the black on and then
we hand write so that every bottle is
unique start to finish from milking the
sheep all the way to bottling the
product it will take at least five
months you'll smell a lot of sweetness
coming through from the milk and then
when you drink it it's going to be
really creamy on the palate and all
have a little milky sort of finished one
of the biggest awards that we won was
world's best vodka which was huge for us
in vodka is not the end for Ryan's
distilling experiments he's also
ventured into gin and now to cue us out
how'd you drink it so treat it really
really similar to a whiskey just nice
and neat even with no ice that's great
that's really smooth it's real hot hmm
beautiful very nice good for doing this
yes definitely
beautiful beautiful to the palate
[Music]